A wonderful way to appreciate this bizarre landscape is from above.
That's why for me, the most exciting balloon ride anywhere in or near Europe is here in Cappadocia.
You get up before sunrise and gather on a desolate field that's become a hive of activity.
Nearly every morning, the scene is the same...
...as noisy burners are fired up and balloons filled.
Climbing into the basket, you meet your captain.
Good morning, everybody!
Morning.
Hi, Mustafa.
My name is Mustafa.
Your pilot was sick, so I will fly you today.
This will be my first day in aviation and I'm really excited.
With the sound of a fire-breathing dragon, you skim the grass and slowly lift off.
While scary for some,...
...the feeling I get is one of graceful stability with majestic views.
Soon, scores of tourist-filled balloons share the sky in silent wonder.